aber wir haben ja auch hier eigentlich
in Deutschland genug Probleme Herr
Hallmann und haben sie uns ja heute eine
These zum mitgebracht wir sind ja gerade
auch nicht dass man kann sagen in der
Hinsicht jetzt nicht was war im betrifft
das Paradebeispiel für die ganze Welt ja
und zwar gleich zweimal also erstens
sind die wahlpannen schon peinlich genug
wenn man dann noch weiß dass der
Bundeswahlleiter das ist ja nicht eine
Person das ist ja ein ganzes Amt vorher
schriftlich wie München mündlich gewarnt
hat und die haben einfach nicht zugehört
und dann haben sie es trotzdem falsch
gemacht und danach wollen sie den
Schaden ja wegdiskutieren
indem sie jetzt im Bundestag nur 431
Stimmbezirke neu wählen lassen wie man
das eigentlich wirklich begründen kann
habe ich noch nicht verstanden und dann
haben sie ja ernsthaften Papier mit über
55 Seiten veröffentlicht dass die
Entscheidung vom
Bundesverfassungsgericht eigentlich zu
überprüfen wäre was sie auch für uns
Inhalte ich hoffe fast dass eine aus der
BVV oder so von der SPD dahin rennt weil
sie würden sich in Karlsruhe aus meiner
Sicht eine abholen
aber wenn man es jetzt zusammenfasst sie
fordern
Neuwahlen
Bundesebene auf Bundesebene ist dies
leider komplizierter die Lage warum jede
Nachwahl schafft neue Ungerechtigkeiten
und deswegen hat das Verfassungsgericht
wie ich finde sehr überzeugend
entschieden in Berlin machen wir es dann
sozusagen gleichmäßig dann ist zwischen
den WLAN niemanden benachteiligt das
geht im Bund ja nicht dann müsste man ja
die ganze Bundestagswahl wiederholen 15
Länder die nichts damit zu tun haben
müssen Leute das geht nicht zweitens
sind Fehler sind bestimmte Fehler nur in
Berlin passiert insbesondere die
vertauschten Stimmzettel drittens
dadurch dass die Ergebnisse bei so viel
mehr Wahlkreisen in Berlin so viel
knapper waren kommt viel mehr also wenn
50 Stimmen fehlen und 1000 Leute durften
nicht richtig wählen dann ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass das was
ausmachen natürlich größer als wenn sie
10000 Stimmen Vorsprung haben und 3000
Leute konnten nicht richtig wählen da
kann das Ergebnis ja nicht anders sein
das Problem ist ja als Bürger kann man
das überhaupt noch ernst nehmen also da
fragt man sich ja wirklich es ist ja wie
sieht Auto und verloren die Frage die
sich ganz billigen
gesagt in Berlin ist die Spitze des
Eisberges einer nicht funktionierenden
öffentlichen Verwaltung eines nicht
funktionierenden öffentlichen Sektors
und das muss dringend ändern werden und
da ist der Flughafen war ein Fanal und
jetzt sind die Wahlen ein Kanal aber es
gibt ja noch viele andere Dinge
nirgendwo muss man so lange am
Standesamt auf einen Termin warten
heiraten zu können die Bürgerämter
Termine klappen seit Jahren
die Schulsanierung klappt nicht also es
ist ja was wäre jetzt die Lösung mehr
Personal einfach oder nein also das ist
leider so verkantet dass man mehrere
Lösungen gleichzeitig machen muss wir
brauchen sicher auch zusätzliches
Personal vor allem brauchen wir das
richtige Personal einen richtigen
Stellen die richtig geführt werden wir
brauchen andere Entscheidungsstrukturen
wir haben ja Entscheidungsstrukturen bei
der es gegenseitige Blockaden gibt also
das Umweltamt sagt der Baum bleibt die
Feuerwehr sagt damit sie ausbauen können
die Feuerwehr sagt der Baum muss weg
sonst kann ich nicht Anleitern diese
Entscheidung bleiben einfach so sind
aber erkennbar widersprüchlich und es
gibt gar keinen System wie es auflösen
können
feststellen würde wird sich denn
überhaupt was ändern jetzt bei Neuwahlen
oder wird sowieso wieder die Regierung
bleiben mit den Farben links bleiben
also jetzt bin ich bekennender und
überzeugt der Bayer und Münchner ich
stecke jetzt nicht ganz so tief in der
Berliner Landespolitik drin aber die
Landtagswahl in Berlin
auch wenn sie Bayer sind natürlich also
wir schauen schon immer ein bisschen auf
Berlin weil ja auch viel von unserem
Geld hier verbaut ist
also was ich also ich denke schon leider
so wie ich das für alle deutschen
zuständig oder natürlich bin ich auf
alle deutschen zuständig deswegen
schauen wir das auch überall gut geht
und gerade in Berlin muss natürlich auch
an als Bundespolitik an ein oder anderen
Stelle nachjustieren die bauen
Wohnungspolitik ist eine Katastrophe
hier übrigens auch gegen die Empfehlung
aller Experten so durchgezogen mit
verheerenden Ergebnissen aber um Ihre
Frage zu beantworten ich also es hängt
natürlich ich weiß nicht davon ab wie
die CDU aufstellt ob die CDU einen
starken Kandidaten aufstellt wir sind
als FDP mit Sebastian Dreyer gut
aufgestellt der wird die FDP auch in den
Wahlkampf führen ich befürchte schon
dass dann gewisses ich glaube man lernt
in Berlin nicht so wirklich wir werden
Ihre Berliner fdp-freunde denn mehr
Stimmen holen können
also ich hoffe sehr wir sind sehr gut
aufgeteilt ja doch also es ist es sind
ein paar unbekannte da also deswegen
kann ich mir schwer das jetzt absolut zu
sagen also wir stehen gut da bist du
noch einen Umfragen bei 7%, das ist für
die FDP sehr sehr stabil es gibt viele
Themen Heimat ein paar angesprochen die
auch für uns sehr sehr relevant sind die
Frage ist was ist die Macht Option also
gibt es eine gibt es eine Mehrheit gegen
Rot-Rot-Grün und dann braucht es die FDP
und das ist für uns ein Thema das ist
sehr sehr stark wir wollen damit
regieren wir haben viele Ideen für
Berlin und berlin braucht eine bessere
Regierung deswegen glaube ich schon wenn
jetzt die Zeit reicht den Wahlkampf gut
zu führen dass die FDP stärker
aussteigen wird aus dem Wahlkampf aber
wieder der FDP noch die CDU hat
Alternativen dargestellt ich kenne ganz
viele Leute die davon
Wahlkabinen standen und nicht
entscheiden konnten auf Berliner Ebene
weil es ist nicht nur rot-rot-grund
sondern werden sie die EU deshalb behält
sich wie ein spd2 und FDP die wir uns
zwei behalten also
Alternativen Politiker das was viele
Berliner also
was haben sie für die waren ja auch an
die Macht und da hat sich nicht so
aussprechen sein Punkt fertig machen ja
sie haben ja auch die waren das ist
nicht dass wir seit Jahrzehnten rot rot
grün gehabt haben sie waren ja auch in
Berlin teil der Koalition und da hat
sich nichts verändert also wir haben
auch große Koalition und ich ich glaube
das was ich alles Berliner fühle von
auch ganz ganz viele anderen die haben
keine Alternativen und ja mit grün grün
rot grün rot rot grün ist Entlastung
Fall aber mit ihnen und mit ihnen haben
wir keine Alternative tut mir leid drei
Punkte das erste ist in der Amtszeit von
der großen Koalition die ja nur fünf
Jahre dauerte haben wir den Berliner
Haushalt saniert und einen Aufschwung
für Berlin organisiert wie wir ihn noch
nicht gesehen haben das wird zwar immer
weggewischt war aber so wir hatten
bessere Zahlen beim Wohnungsbau viel
bessere Zahlen als wir heute haben sie
waren immer noch nicht gut genug aber
sie waren klar steigend und sie waren
besser was wir nicht hinbekommen haben
auch das ist Teil der Wahrheit ist eine
vernünftige Verwaltungsmodernisierung
dafür ist Frank Henkel damals auch
abgestraft worden
jetzt bei der letzten Wahl war es so
dass die Berliner landesthemen ja gar
nicht so richtig zu Vorschein kam weil
wir gleichzeitig Bundestagswahl haben
das wird ja jetzt im Februar anders
werden
kleine Aufklärung Kai Wegner wird unter
Spitzenkandidat werden die und wir haben
bei der Frage des Wohnungsbaus bei der
Frage der Wirtschaftsförderung
inzwischen bei der Frage wie machen wir
eigentlich verwaltungsmodellisierung und
insbesondere auch Berlin ist ja auch zum
Schlusslicht beim Thema Klimaschutz 22
Gebäude öffentliche Gebäude von 1000
haben ein Solardach die quatschen hier
auch nur und machen nichts ja und
seitdem haben sie vergessen Integration
und Kriminalität die die es gibt noch
mehr Themen ist gar keine Frage aber ich
und natürlich müssten wir beim Thema
Durchsetzen von polizeilichen Mitteln
bei der Bekämpfung des Themas dass sie
sehr beschäftigt ihn nicht
zusammengefasst also man kann das ja
immer mit so zahlen und so schön aber
irgendwie hat man ja schon das Gefühl
hier in Berlin klappt einfach nichts und
ja man so hat er gerade was tut sie
nicht so da geben sie da sind wir schon
mal alleine Meinung und Sie haben gerade
was ganz spannendes angesprochen dass
sie das Gefühl haben dass auch FDP und
Union Mogelpackungen sind und eigentlich
gerade gesagt
dass die zum Teil nicht durchgedrungen
sind ist leider auch die Wahrheit aber
die wir haben durchaus Alternativen man
muss ja nichts klar sagen wird man wird
in fünf Jahren das
Verwaltungssystem in Berlin nur
schrittweise umbauen können das heißt
nicht wenn morgen die CDU regiert haben
sie übermorgen überall Bürgeramt Termine
sitzt so tief dass man dafür auch eine
radikalkung
zuhört und Politiker sagt also in fünf
Jahren kann ich da jetzt nichts groß
verändern vielleicht ist es ehrlich aber
es ist weiter technisch nicht so klug
oder aber ehrlich gesagt es gibt ja auch
noch mal einen Tag nach der Wahl und
wenn sie jetzt lauter versprechen machen
die sie dann am Tag nachher gleich
wieder einkassieren müssen ich glaube
die Bürger wollen über die weiteren es
ist ein ganz verfestigtes Problem dass
wir seit Jahrzehnten in Berlin haben und
dazu werden wir sehr sehr starke
Maßnahmen vorliegen
Berlin droht der verwaltungsnotstand
weil es lauter Faktoren gibt die das
Problem noch verschärfen will ein
Drittel des öffentlichen Dienstes geht
in diesem Jahr zehn im Pension ich
musste es gibt
keine digitalen Systeme
drei Punkte drei Punkte würde ich gerne
machen
also genau das ist eigentlich die Tragik
der CDU in Berlin dass sie jetzt vier
Probleme beschreiben das kann ich auch
das können auch viele Leute wir wollen
Lösungen weil wir satt haben dass wir in
Berlin als arbeitender Menschen nicht
der Service nicht die das bekommen was
ein normaler Bürger in ein Land wie
Deutschland bekommen soll und das ist
das Problem also bieten Sie bitte
Lösungen und ich bin der erste dabei
ihnen bin aber muss ich nochmal drei
drei Punkte machen weil wir auch mit
angesprochen sind also
sogar den Bayer fällt ja mehr ein als im
Berliner CDU aber was man in Berlin
machen kann was was mir von außen
besache relevant entscheiden und die FDP
Berlin hat es auch eine Wahlprogramm in
Berlin braucht eine Strukturreform sie
haben in dieser Bezirksämter zu viel
eigene Macht
ausgelagert die sich widersprechen da
ist tatsächlich die Struktur ähnlich wie
wir auch mal über den Föderalismus in
Deutschland reden müssen da hat Berlin
eine Struktur aufgebaut die muss
geändert werden das ist jetzt ein
technisches Arbeitnehmer das wird
wahrscheinlich kein Wähler hinter dem
Ofen hervorholen aber da müssen wir ran
ist es wichtig zweitens wenn Hermann so
als Berliner sagt wir beide bieten keine
Alternative dann müssen wir es ernst
nehmen dann wäre ich jetzt nicht
erzählen was ich alles Tolles gemacht
habe für Berlin sondern da müssen wir
schauen wie erreichen unsere Botschaften
die Berlinerinnen Wähler und Wähler das
ist die zweite wichtige Aufgabe der wir
uns verpflichtet fühlen und das dritte
also die Feststellung wir brauchen die
richtigen Leute zur richtigen Zeit in
der richtigen Stelle und die müssen wir
gut bezahlen das ist ja in Zeiten des
Fachkräftemangel mangels einfach
Wunschdenken die Struktur angehen die
Verwaltung digitalisieren sie müssen in
die Bildung investieren und zwar so dass
es kracht das ist kracht
von außen zu machen
aber das mit der Digitalisierung glaubt
doch in Deutschland mittlerweile auch
schon leider keiner mehr also da reden
wir jetzt gefühlt seit zehn Jahren
drüber und das Problem ist doch auch bei
diesen ganzen Strukturen irgendwie
entflechten das Ganze zusammen kürzen
das funktioniert doch nicht im Endeffekt
so ein Staat der immer größer wird der
müsste sich ja selber abschaffen das ist
ja genau wie eine Arbeiterpartei die
sich eigentlich auf die Fahnen schreibt
den Arbeitern muss es gut gehen aber
wenn es durchgehen würde dann wäre quasi
die Arbeiterpartei am Ende und ich
glaube einfach nicht dass ich der
Bundestag wird immer größer
welche Struktur schafft sich denn ja
Kanzleramt auch und das kostet auch noch
von absolut welche Struktur schafft sich
denn selber ab also das sind in der
Richtung also wir haben das in
Deutschland immer nur nach großen Krisen
so und Berlin muss wahrscheinlich die
Krise groß genug sein dass wir den Mut
haben die Entscheidung zu treffen ich
muss die Krise in Berlin dennoch werden